we're still a week away from the destiny
console launch but for right now PC
players get to play their own beta which
includes a new crucible map called
javelin for the map appears to take
place in a wars' at launch silo that
could be tied to a story mission maybe
around Rasputin and striking back
against the red Legion do not forget to
stop during one of your matches and
check out that beautiful view of Jupiter
the PC version is set to come out at the
end of October and has the chance to
bring in new players who didn't
experience the game on console what do
you think worth the wait for mouse and
keyboard and maybe some better graphics
let's discuss in the comments below
thanks for watching
don't see captured you have advantage
[Music]
three minutes remaining zone beadlock
don't see captured stolen parties
to finish it
zone advantage is yours
don't be long five minutes remaining
zone seed loss don't be lost he captured
Zone C zone advantage is yours
keep this up and the bottle is yours own
a loss five minutes
don't be captured no impossible
what can stop you if you fight together
nothing
don't be captured you have zone
advantage zone a loss
oh I can't wait to see what you do with
that
Zone B lost your enemy has a power place
you captured zone a don't be captured
do you have zone advancing
don't see captured power play keep the
pressure on
three minutes you're evenly matched
don't seed lost you can't believe don't
see captured that's a power play you
took them now hold
this and the bottle is yours don't be
lost
double down donate capture you have
solid fun
zone seed no don't be
capture zone embosses if you'll keep it
up and victory is yours zone a loss
one minute
yes now show them the true meaning of
war zone seed captured you haven't
bothered you captured zone a 30 seconds
remaining power play keep the pressure
on you fight like a debug for these
zones bring me your friends I need more
like you